brutalities have been teased multiple
times now both on the Mortal Kombat X
live stream as well as a tweet made by
netherrealm studios earlier today saying
it's going to be brutal we can also see
that brutalities have been shown as a
challenge in their mortal kombat x next
video all these signs point to brutality
is probably making their way back in
Mortal Kombat X if you're not familiar
with brutalities there are another form
of mortal kombat fatalities which
included baby allottees anna maladies
and friendships brutalities allow the
players to do long combos that
ultimately blew up their opponent you
could even argue that brutalities are
similar to killer instincts ultra combos
this could be a move by another room to
show their dominance in finishers it'll
be interesting to see just how brutal
these new brutalities are compared to
their previous iterations as many of the
fatalities and even x-rays seem to show
more detail and gore in Mortal Kombat X
from bone crunching spines to
eye-popping action just how brutal will
it be
you